you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar evolution in the manufacturing
of cellular therapies lessons learned
and current solutions I'm Alexis Krause
of laberd's and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lappers and
brought to you by Beckman Coulter life
sciences to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.meliar.com/mpanel.htm
I'm four at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right at the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on my ask a question
box located on the far left your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker Neal Kyle
global biopharma Manager cell and gene
therapy commercialization at Beckman
Coulter Neal it has a long-standing
interest in the cellular manufacturing
process with the overarching intent of
democratization in personalized
medication he trained in bioengineering
and functional medical resonance imaging
at Temple University with a focus on
spinal cord injury in pediatric
population his research was not on
non-invasively quantifying healthy
neuronal tissues as a pre Optus
neurosurgery's at Beckman Coulter and
Neil Kyle manages the globe loop excuse
me the global biopharm of business
commercializing the life science
portfolio in the cell and gene therapy
market for a complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
Neil you may now begin your present
thank you thank you everybody for
joining today we have this opportunity
to kind of talk about this new very
exciting field of cellular therapies and
with the recent success of the car T
cell therapy there's been a renewed
interest in bio processing and the
manufacturing facilities required to
meet this demands today we want to
examine some of the barriers and
advantages of how to automate this
manufacturing process additionally we'll
look into a little discussion of
automating and autologous car T cell
process a detailed discussion of looking
at each step from collection to infusion
and discussing the current offerings we
have as well as the lessons we have
learned
our agenda for today to look at the
landscape of the adoptive cellular
therapy space-car pages being one of
them giving it as a breakdown of the
different trials that are ongoing some
of them which has achieved the our map
status and we'll talk about that the
different challenges we are facing today
moving into what does the manufacturing
process how is it evolving based on the
lessons we have learned from the
different studies ongoing trials moving
into what does fully automated
manufacturing 2.0 look like then we'll
dive deep into what the spectrum culture
life sciences as a company brings bring
to this application workflow going from
all the way from collection to infusion
and then we'll have some time to follow
up with questions and and answer some of
the some of your questions that come up
the therapy is the transplantation of
human cells to replace or repair damaged
tissue and our cells with new
technologies in our very products and of
course limitless imagination many
different types of cells may be used as
a part of a therapy or treatment for a
variety of diseases and conditions if
you look at the slide the potential
applications of cell therapies include
treating cancers to immune disease
urinary problems infectious diseases
rebuilding damaged cartilage in joints
repairing spinal cord injuries as well
as improving a weakened immune system
slide kind of breaks down all the
different regenerative medicine
companies that are working on
challenging therapy trying to achieve to
go from the regenerative medicine
advanced therapy designation or arm at
status to into a fully commercialized
portfolio so this gives you a very nice
breakdown of all the different companies
working worldwide
so one of the interesting things that
was discussed at Alliance regenerative
medicine meeting earlier this year in
Washington DC it's kind of understand
the different trials the different
phases these clinical trials are and
some of these companies as I mentioned
working on the regenerative medicine
advanced therapy designation with all
the different cell therapy products
which might not be all the way
commercialized to what we know today as
chimera and XSL but the companies that
are working on moving things along in
terms of cell gene and modified cell
therapies
so here you see some of the already
commercialized and approved therapies
from FDA and EMA Novartis chimera for
pediatric acute lymphoblastic leukemia
and adult diffuse large cell b-cell
lymphoma as well as Gilead Sciences here
scarda for adult diffuse large b-cell
lymphoma however in December bloomberg
reported that only five patients had
December 2017 that is a bloomberg
reported that only five patients had
received ES Carter since its approval in
particularly because there is difficulty
in and understanding the insurance
coverage for the therapy plus the
supported care costs one of the things
that to be noted here is as some of
these big farmers moving the development
of car t-cells the pricing concerns have
also come up so and then you add this to
the drugs maybe something some instances
cases potential you know side effects
and difficulties in manufacturing the
cells it's clear that you know we have a
lot more hurdles to jump before this new
cell therapy can become widely available
so as we see you know almost every other
institution is working on a city
nineteen based therapy to combat
leukemia since its accounts for almost
nine point four percent of around two
million people newly diagnosed people in
the u.s. just alone that's roughly about
fifty five thousand people and acute
lymphoblastic leukemia are ALL is as we
know highly prevalent among children as
well as accounts for about forty percent
of the cases in adults
so manufacturing you know Carty looks
great in the clinic right that's well
understood in the labs but how do you
scale up how do we come from the clinic
and go into full-scale manufacturing
setting so at the same Alliance
regenerative medicine board meeting in
DC earlier this year there'll be a
commissioner came out and said you know
there is a bigger need for the tool
providers companies like Beckman Coulter
and others to work hand in hand with our
potential other companies that are
working on their designated regions in
medicine sell products to figure out the
gaps the loopholes the the challenges
and most importantly figure out a way to
decrease the cost of goods and have a
more efficient supply chain to be able
to bring this really wonderful living
drugs to the market more easily so this
is a really well understood problem
gives you a breakdown of the landscape
the darkest old cell therapy or ECT
landscape is a rapidly evolving category
of targeted cell therapies for the
treatment of cancer and includes car T
cell T car T cell T C R therapeutics
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes tails but
at the most basic level these adaptive
cell cellular therapies involves genetic
engineering of our immune cells most
commonly the immune T cells outside of
the body - so that we can target the
proteins or protein fragments on the
cancer cells
okay moving into the manufacturing
process and how it's been evolving right
so the first thing that we need to
understand is the product must be
affordable for the acceptance for public
acceptance as a therapeutic option there
has been much debate on what the cost of
this therapy should be and there is a
discrepancy between the expected and the
actual selling price of a cell therapy
the International Society of cell
therapy RIS CT subcommittee posted a
survey that showed the labor and
materials to be an estimated average of
61 percent of the total cost of goods in
terms of constraints in manufacturing
that were designated as rate limiting
and that contributes substantially to
increase cost the people who took the
survey cited the lack of automation and
manpower ahead of the other regulatory
concerns or materials and even testing
so this is what a manufacturing 1.0 look
like right so everything is very manual
we're trying trying to understand how we
can transfer this tech from the lab
setting from an academic facility to do
a manufacturing setting to scale it up
at this point it's just the very
beginning of the process and a lot of
the processes are open it's kind of
complex there's a lot of variability in
the way we quantify or we try we want to
set up a supply chain and you know there
are a lot of things on manual and you
need to you know understand how can we
move from this step to maybe move into a
more of a tremendous setup
what you know the experts in the field
think that should be the way moved to
move forward with right so on one hand
you should have an integrated way of
automating and closing out all the
different unit operations that go into
the manufacturing at the same time have
the flexibility to change the secret
sauce or as the science evolved to
change them the way you manufacture
however make it so easily transferable
so that you can bring it back into your
developed or integrate operations this
idea is to reduce the variation increase
your robustness and control by the same
time be open to figuring out what are
the new things that you are learning
along the way so you can incorporate
those change in a very easy and feasible
fashion
so two providers right do providers as
in people like making culture people
like myself people like you know people
who are in this field working with out
with different customers you know we
have this we have this thing we need to
understand how how the field is evolving
you know and what can we do to be able
to adapt in to provide the services that
we can provide to our customers in terms
of understanding them understand how to
quickly bring about transformative fixes
that bring in the most amount of value
so that they don't have their automated
process is open enough to accept those
transformative fixes by the same time
stay closed enough to have that scale-up
capability so in essence if I I always
try to bring in some analogies we need
to understand where to skate to kind of
beforehand determine where the puck is
going to be this is from Wayne Gretzky
and I know that really resonates to in
terms of what us as the tool providers
we need to understand so that we can
bring in the value as the FDA
Commissioner had mentioned earlier this
year at Alliance meeting
so this brings about some of the current
challenges to cell therapy so it can be
grouped into four key areas quality
scalability sustainability and
robustness of the supply chain to manage
the cost of goods now while there are
two different kind of ways that the
current solutions in the market is
presented one you have your modular
breadmaker model as it's called which
you know which kind of provides you with
a better flexibility but at the same
time it can also kind of limits you to
make changes or bring and bring about
the different changes to adapt to the
process as your science the science
evolves so although it provides a lot of
you know in a yield a higher suite of
productivity and flexibility it also has
some disadvantages on the other hand you
have the integration of different
smaller unit operations which not only
brings makes it completely automated so
you're taking the kind of art out of the
sides making it open for innovation and
that also helps you to have a you know
kind of better understanding how to
streamline your consumable usage and
provide that higher scale up or higher
suite of productivity
so at Becca Colter we definitely believe
in the integration of different unit
operations which can result in fewer
touches so that you can have that
increased process innovation and and get
that higher productivity we are looking
for and their reasons why we follow this
principle for one of the different
things we have learned right
one of the things that how does it
impact the patient in terms of
pretreatment so studies show and there
are plenty of data that show that it's
one cohort of patients of CLL patients
when they were treated with it
lieutenant
for more than a year the diesel
isolations for this patients going
through CTL or 19 expansion they should
much better clinical response so and and
that kind of makes it better to
understand that when it comes to karti
that there the impact of pretreatment
can have significant more valid value to
get a better clinical response now if
you have a closed system a completely
modular closed system it will be pretty
difficult to bring about this sort of
mean changes as you learn as people
learn from different trials and
different studies because those those
systems are modular but definitely not
open to be incorporated those changes
what else did we learn right so there
was this recent publication where they
talked about how a single remnant
leukemic b-cell can destroy the entire
compartment right so how does how does
one account for those things so the
authors concluded by saying that in in
terms of all the different polychromatic
assays there has to be some sort of MRD
test to get the idea for those minimal
residual disease a phase two can look at
those specific expressions to understand
how can they make this better while it
might be very difficult to account for a
single remnant leukemic self at the same
time what the authors primarily stressed
on is
process cannot be closed enough because
if the process is closed things like
this will be remiss and we need to be
aware of the use end and get it out into
the markets the people understand that
this processes need to be open-ended at
the same time closed enough to provide
you the scale-up
opportunities
we
the things we learned is the quality of
the starting material it's very
important we need to have a better
understanding of the phenotypes that are
going in the raw material the phenotype
of the raw materials going into the
processed and and and how can you assess
that there has to be a way of making
sure that this phenotypes cd8 positive
city 45 are a positive ccr7 positive
cells are available into the raw
material going from after nucleus is
going going into the activation stage so
that studies show that the patient the
CLL patients who had a higher proportion
of these phenotypes you know provided a
much better clinical response when
treated with the CTL or 19 expansion now
having this on an integrated system
within these operations is easy to
incorporate while if you're working with
a locked-in breadmaker model as per se
that becomes very challenging
now going from a very making up you know
making a single-dose to you know making
a single-dose to making a batch of a
living drug this is where it's moving
towards the industrialization of it and
for this reason you know this is a
process that needs to be well understood
and a strategy for making the desired
changes and as our understanding
increases so should the ability to
optimize and control the process for
example it sells destined for a clinical
trial should be consistent and of
uniform population or not because when
you go to a cell expansion process
inherently it produces heterogeneity
within the patch and most likely it is
due to the cell micro environment so we
need to figure out how we can bring
about this industrialization to go to go
into making a full full-faced scalar
process and account for the different
variables and factors that might be rate
limiting
these are some of the key parameters
that are collected during cell therapy
production from cell count volume and
Beckman Coulter we are uniquely
positioned to be able to offer a set of
unit operations which are pretty much
golden standard in a class of its own
from viable cell count using our buy
cell fully automated - glue exclusion
principle with the ability to optimize
and analyze settings - moving on to
getting a better understanding of how
can we be able do a label free method
understanding the change in cell volume
the multi sizes which is our you know
does the exact same process it can go
down to almost point to micrometer in
sizing range not only gives you size but
also gives you the Delta in the change
in cell volume the aggregate detection
same thing before formulation it's able
to understand that aggregate detection
moving in to understand again the
genetic expression the surface
expression of the reporter gene function
the side effects which its opinion
technology providing exceptional
sensitivity across the entire visible
spectrum and then the metabolic
indicators you know when you're growing
your cells in the bio reactors how do
you get this in process control
completely automated to the meta flex
provides you this by a light analyzer
evaluating the pH glucose lactates
electrolytes in a highly automated
fashion I'm going to talk about these
things and how they fit into a fully
automated autologous cardi cell process
and we'll talk about this place shortly
you
so to automate a process a multi-step
process like this it's not easy right so
it must first be broken down into key
unit operations and the granularity of
the skee unit operations may be limited
by the bioprocess equipment available
for the each step of the process but it
may also reflect the current
understanding of the of how this is
worked out and likely be phased up as we
learn more and more about this process
and that's why having a set of key unit
operations automated onto a same
platform makes a whole lot more sense
the goal ultimately is to have as I
mentioned is the factory automation to
take the idea of this unit operation to
whole new levels so we can collect all
this sort of executing all the systems
executing these functions and have the
big data collection going on in the
backend so we can track the pop drag the
whole process
since our rendition of how a car t-cell
creational journey for diesel happens
from the again from collection to
infusion and how we provide these unit
operations with all our different
product lines to go after or kind of
unpaid or understand these processes in
in detail because what important things
to understand is for when it comes to
car diesel creation the process is the
product so automation can reduce or
eliminate a number of this open
operations because we have to mitigate
the risk of microbial contamination for
cell therapy processes in particular the
final product and cells cannot be
filtered or sterilized so microbial
contamination and other products on
compliance will only contribute to
increasing the cost of good especially
when the cell product is lost so I want
to break down this this particular slide
in the next couple of slides to kind of
walk you guys through in how we perceive
this and how our what are the workflows
we are put together to integrate each
and every single one of these integrated
operations into the autologous car
t-cell process
so from leukapheresis isolation of
b-cells we need to have an understanding
of cell count and the viability of this
living cells there has to be a weight of
rapid equal plasma testing utilizing
qPCR understanding the phenotype of the
Roma treatment of the cells or materials
going into the activation stage and also
as I mentioned account for the flap in
microbial testing to ensure that we can
mitigate that
is how we do it so I'll talk in more
detail about the biomech but as I
measure in my earlier slides with the
vital force and counting
site of flags for phenotyping as well as
raw material testing do a clone our
unitized write-down reagent products and
at the same time all the sizer to
understand the sizing of the cells
you're going to see these product names
pop up as we move along the process and
I'll explain how they play into the
field moving into the activation of the
t-cells whether it's a be based
activators or transposons or sleeping
beauty a way to understand how to
activate these cells based on the beads
and understanding how it changes the
cell volume the Delta and cell volume
and thus and how we can characterize the
different size the multi size it does a
really good job at it and I'm going to
show you guys some data of how its
achieved so using the multi sizer when
you're Dee beading or understanding that
they'll Pender cell volume change here
we are looking at say at day 0 after
time so there exists two different
populations one population to the left
consisting of primarily your debris and
the population up on your right
represented the inactivated cells so
following stimulation the population on
the right which is which are the
activated cells they grow in volume
until they reach a peak size of say 766
50 liters the population on the left
consisting of smaller particles is not
very important or relevant in terms of
the decision making process of this
harvesting cells rather in this case the
QC technician is monitoring when the
cell volume has reached a peak which is
depicted in on day 5 at day 7 the volume
of cells has begun to shrink relative to
what we see in day 5 and now the medium
cell volume is around 500 centiliters
and by a day 10 the cells have shrunk to
about 300 397 2 liters
so what our understanding is and in
collaboration with our partners in
different farmers and they have
indicated that the cells add the maximum
volume show maximum effectiveness in
killing the cancer cells
moving on from that process to the gene
transfer a transaction delivery of the
vowel vector which has to be delivered
in very small doses and we have to
ensure that we are swapping out the
Culture Media in the bioreactor
for enrichment of the cells and by
upscaling it by phone Michael leaders at
a time so that to ensure that the F
phase of the growth phase is consistent
making sure we check the health of the
metabolites that we can implement this
change of the cell media the meta flex
as I had mentioned plays a vital key
role it in this step there are different
by process analytical technologies
people are even using pH strips to
understand the health of the metabolites
moving forward but the meta flicks our
bath and a lot analyzers able to obtain
these results in as little as 30 seconds
and with very little volume
- t-cell expansion we have to understand
the cell volume and size analysis and
also once we have the finished product
we have to phenotype it again to
understand the cytotoxicity of this car
t-cells and how how that interacts
before we move into formulation
not to mention on this step the same
time that this will need to be analyzed
and the data needs to be collected and
it entered with a desk to analyze system
or a whole gambit of data analytics
architecture because big data is the
current mantra around cell manufacturing
because when the process is the product
any measurable change in the culture has
to be recorded and corrected if needed
and then it moves into infusion but one
of the things that the big farmers and
even the our partners we work with have
mentioned is the manufacturing process
the manufacturing and testing processes
have to be moved to clean rooms or to a
controlled non-classified spaces and and
in this is the only way we can work with
multiple patient samples and they can be
they can be handled simultaneously which
will then address to facilitate a
high-volume production and in those
regards our met ones clean room
monitoring system plays a vital key role
in the in its ability to be able to move
things to a non classified space
okay moving into how are we going to
bring together all these different unit
operations to the same platform so the
biomech our liquid handler is at the
heart at the very core of all our unit
operations it has the capability to
connect to integrate multiple different
automation friendly energy operation and
functional devices onto its grid so that
we can offer this sort of a closed
enough but still open for innovation
system when we think of automated
functional testing this just gives you a
representation of how you can combine up
from a cell cell washer to a cell shaker
to a flow cytometer and even a liquid
handler to kind of understand how we can
achieve this sort of automated
functional testing setup the
capabilities of the biomech system a
liquid handling system is it's very
versatile it provides us with you know
whether you want to launch free program
methods that we have developed of the
protocols to run from us suite of test
menus making sure that we are able to
prevent user errors at the same time
restricting methods that are available
to operators and open up to an audit
trail methods to be verified for 21 CFR
part 11 compliance the software
capabilities like dart is sort of like
at the center of the accusation and
understanding reporting all these
different data analytics that's that's
collected because as I mentioned what I
think big thing for cell therapy is we
need to be able to measure any change in
the culture it needs to be recorded and
it needs to be corrected
ese as we know is very laborious it's
very time-consuming it's very you know
tedious to perform it has so many
different steps but when you when we
think about if we can figure out a way
to automate this functional assay into
simple use simple user-friendly steps
utilizing the liquid handlers with our
other unit operations it makes a lot
more sense
so as
of a more deeper workflow automation
understanding we can integrate
additional functions and devices this
this sort of a deck space is with a grid
allows for easy installation of
different lab where positions and
accessories so whatever the needs are
are we with the needs need to change or
we have to quickly change or adjust to
different workflows whether activation
or expansion it can be done pretty
easily and and turnaround is pretty
quick the frame of these new systems
provide you know enhance accessibility
for more future device integration so
it's still keeping things open-ended so
that we can change or adapt as the
science changes or evolves along the way
it's been looking for in a Carty process
looking for a specific surface marker or
a reporter gene expression as well as
understanding the correct cell types
isolated and enrich those optometry
plays a big role in in the research cell
type whether it's cell therapy research
or in a GMP setting so when we bring
these two different technologies
together the configuration is able to
completely automate say an antibody
based staining or acquisition of samples
without even any user intervention this
system could pretty much run on our
famiiy software to enable multiple
families of plates to be processed
sequentially with consistent timing
making sure all the plates are treated
the same and the results can be compared
across across the different studies
this giving you an idea an example of
what an integrated set will look like in
terms of when we understand understand
out when you're bringing together flow
cytometry with liquid handling
centrifugation cell counting how would
it fit in the scheme whether it's
collecting up to 15 parameters are
moving into acquisition of almost 49
different parameters it has the ability
to incorporate the different tools of
going from understanding whether it's
what didn't meet what the needs are it
can quickly evolve based on the
instrumentation a centrifuge orbital
shaker a plate washer and even incubator
to ensure dark incubations when you're
working with light sensitive reagents
but still living leaving dead space
available and open for eventual more
sample processing
so when we think of an automated
functional testing our our you know so
that we can we can quickly characterize
cell therapy manufacturing process this
is what it looks like to us from sample
prep to reagents moving into
instrumentation as well as the big data
the metadata analysis and doing it in a
clean and non-classified room with the
help of the metal insistence we get this
set up a fully integrated workflow which
is able to provide us with the
functional tests that we are interested
in doing across the board and and not
just limiting it to what it has to offer
today but at the same time keeping it
open enough to bring in other changes
whether that's understanding the
stability or the potency or even doing
receptor occupancy or cell signaling as
well as your classical you know
phenotyping assays
looking into you know understanding how
can we bring down the cost of goods
especially from our raw material
perspective especially from a consumable
perspective how can we streamline these
so as I said flow cytometry plays a very
very very interesting part very vital
key part in there I want the things that
goes into the processes how can we
quickly test the phenotype of the cells
without bringing in any variability from
batch to batch as well as do a quick
kisi release passed on the finished
Carty product before we release it out
for formulation so we we have our
proprietary drive down technology which
provides a very comprehensive range of
immune system monitoring and these are
unitized dried down classified
antibodies which the steps are as simple
as moving on from adding whole blood
sample to these tubes or plates adding
your lysis buffer washing it and
acquiring it on the samples because
these tubes are plates are optimized for
the identification and characterization
of the cells of the immune system so if
you look at it this actually the way we
develop this panels it came out of the
one study protocol one study program
which is recognized as like a reference
or golden reference in multi-site
standardization it's probably the first
time it's a the very first time a
unified approach to characterize
cellular tolerance induction so some of
these tubes whether you want to
delineate principle lymphocytes based on
that as a population of of monocytes are
understanding the lead maturation stages
of the B cell to understanding the
different T cells covering naive
effector memory or even terminal of the
fresh differentiation stages it provides
you the flexibility to really streamline
your workflow
we did a comparison between because idea
is to reduce the cost of goods right we
need to be able to figure out a decision
on whether and when up what are the
long-term consequences of whenever we
are developing these therapies the cost
reviews should definitely be at the back
of our head if you want to bring the
overall cost down so for that reason we
did a comparison between what does it
look like between a drive to a liquid
cocktail and and and and to get you guys
a better understanding this is a this is
a set of PV NK panel with normal whole
blood prepared with with the lysis
reagent and we kind of overlaid the two
different data sets to kind of kind of
make a point that the sensitivity and
the performance stays just the same if
not better so to give you understanding
the red the red overlaid on the blue on
the on the blue so blue would be the
liquid and the red would be the dry
reagents hardly any difference at beacon
we can speak of
so moving into uh again how do we kind
of takes all these functional assays and
automated with our liquid handling
platform and add in those centrifugation
steps both viable cell counting
viability steps and the suppose
atomically workflow steps so as you know
for photometry has a number of sample
prep challenges if you're working with
the editor and cell line the need to
have single cell suspension samples
means you have to have a robust Chris
crystallization and resuspension and
most self-training workflows require
region exchanges and and resuspension
meaning that you need a centrifugation
step for this exchanges and washes
another consideration is the limitations
on sample throughput driven by whether
the città meter takes in your tubes or
your samples whether it's in tubes or
power plates so here we show a 13 color
panel of using our drive down reagents
and then we try that with drop in some
liquid markers and we try to understand
how is this corner pan out when we try
to do it in a high-throughput automated
fashion so the idea is sort of
integrating it into a liquid into a
liquid handling platform in with
multi-channel heads or you know at least
a span eight for you know eight
different pickups and adding in this
integration for the washes incubation as
well as the shaker and last but not the
least the site ometer the side of legs
for doing the phenotypes so why do this
right one of the questions is why do we
need to have this sort of a fast
high-throughput method so if your
traffic screening is a powerful tool for
drug identification because in these
assays can be run without even any prior
understanding of the target and the
primary cells which closely make the
therapeutic setting if we have so
advanced automation and high content
imaging has well made this possible but
are still relatively sloped so to
address this limitation we have
developed this sort of automated
workflow that is dedicated to processing
the complex phenotypic assays for flow
cytometry the systems can achieve a
throughput of almost 50,000 wells per
day resulting in fully automated
platform that enables you know very
robust phenotype big drug discovery so
to show you guys some data here the
sequential gating to kind of you know if
you look at from the blue to red you
have your CD 3 positive cd4 positive
helped with these cells from blue to the
city 3 positive
cd8 positive side are 60 cells in red
I'm not going to walk you guys through
the entire thing but it's kind of just
makes makes it understand how we can
achieve this sort of a really powerful
screening technique to test the whether
is testing the raw materials going into
the Carty process or testing the
finished product coming out of the
process utilizing a best of the ball
both words in it operations of
write-down antibody reagents integrated
onto a automated platform with cell
counting viability testing santa
fication and as well as flow cytometry
okay this is a kind of taking it to
where we are in terms of taking this
sort of the next step to working with
different collaborators in here they
show a purified car t-cell exposed to
the target expressing cell lines we have
three different constructs long short
and of two different generation and we
want to check the potency of this car
construct activated by the antigen in
situ the car positive and the car
negative and kind of understand the
amplitude in correlation with what's
happening in vivo so the couple things
that mostly interest us are and I think
our collaborators is understanding the
specificity the amplitude whether it's
enhanced domain 3:28 or for one BB and
also understanding the signal intensity
per cell and how it acts or against the
different pro-inflammatory cytokines was
the best TNF alpha production positive
negative looking at the multi level
cytokine expression some sort of quick
check to check the raw materials to
check the finished product I'm sorry
to understand the cytotoxicity of this
cells before we move it into formulation
so as I started my presentation in the
very beginning and I mentioned you know
that this is pretty clear there are
several different opportunities to work
together so that you know we can address
a plethora of different reasons or in
whether that's a barrier or whether
that's a you know advantage of how we
can automate this sort of a process very
complicated process and provide and get
a better deeper understanding of how we
can maintain the consequence II and
tailor the automation to feed the fit
the process because here the process is
the product
so that leads us to the end of the
presentation and I guess it's time for
some answers
Thank You Neil for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left to your
screen and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is you
mentioned about the multi sizer
technology for cell sizing and counting
but doesn't flow cytometry metric cells
counters have the same functionality
okay I would say a great question yes
that's correct
low cytometry can provide the same
functionality when it comes to cell
sizing but so sizing is then the only
reason why multitude of this biopharma
and academic labs are utilizing the
multi sizer
to kind of give you some more
granularity and examples lobbyist
companies our institutions are utilizing
the multi sizer to establish some sort
of a baseline like a like a correlation
and calibration of actual flow cytometry
scattering data to actual real-world
size numbers if you take a example of
any company you know a company across
different geographies
there are R&D sites might have different
flow cytometry technology right so how
do we bring them to the same page how do
we ensure that they're speaking the same
language
that's what the multi sizer does it
establishes a baseline so that we can
relate to it I remember a publication
from June and Gillett all that came out
last year in molecular biology methods
where the lab was used able to use the
multi sizer to convert flows scattering
data flow cytometry scattering data to
femtometers which provided the group
with the metric of cells that was not
influenced by different tip not flow
cytometry technologies that are
available so now they can easily move
from one vendor to the other and be able
to use the multi sizer to standardize
the scattering mean of the scattering
mean across different instrumentation
additionally the multi sizer gives you a
better understanding of adjusting the
ratios of the beads to cells for
stimulation purposes and at the same
time counting cells although flow
cytometry can count cells but many
events are necessary
not necessarily cells and hence
therefore you need a dedicated cell
counter for cell counts now to floor
metrics or counters are definitely an
alternative but the multi sizer is
preferred because not only is it giving
you a size distribution but it's also
counting at the same time
now nail our next question how does
fluorescence based cell sorting fit into
the car team manufacturing settings okay
so I'm guessing you're referring to
facts so so slow cell sorting is
routinely used in research environments
to select specific cell population based
on the surface markers however in this
case of cell therapy manufacturing cell
flow sorting is kind of inefficient
because you have to sort a large
population of cells and and hence the
throughput is slow and most importantly
most of these flow cells orders are
droplet based so we'll be susceptible to
contamination there are some closed
cartridge based systems microfluidic
based systems that have been introduced
to kind of resolve this problem but the
sorting rates still remain relatively
very slow at about 30,000 events per
second
the other thing from a very formal APM
on the bench when you isolating these
cells we have to culture them and
sometimes it can backfire if you don't
have the right amount of cd4 and cd8 it
can skew your cytokine in the cocktail
some of the really experienced labs are
not even adding any cytokines in their
culture to eliminate the addition of any
stimulation of the bands of beads and
then when you take this sort of a
sorting setup and take it for
experimental reasons it could also lead
to some regulatory bottlenecks as well
so for that reason flow starting well
though it's used in the R&D side of
testing price elation purposes not so
much for GMP and that's that's that's
kind of reason why some of these
magnetic activated cell sorting setups
have have become popular but even those
have some disadvantages because you have
to remove them remove the beads and that
can add to overall cost my might I guess
my my two cents in my opinion it would
be that we need to have an increase
understanding of the target cells so
that we can reduce the number of number
of cells required for this treatment but
I don't think we're there yet and maybe
we'll get there and maybe even have some
sort of a better technique to to kind of
address this gap in in in the industry
you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question so we'll close out with
this one what in your opinion needs to
change for hospitals and clinics to
become more successful excuse me to
become successful decentralized
manufacturing centers
thank you for the question
so I actually come from a family of
doctors and I can tell you this
clinicians they want to have control
over how they treat their patient they
want to have absolute control and and
since now we are talking about living
drugs they also want to have control
over the manufacturing of this living
cells so that they can treat their
patients in a timely fashion and have
more of an accountability on the whole
process so for this particular reason
the hospitals want to become primary
sites for that the ex vivo therapies can
be performed at the patient bedside
if you think about
they induced to report in terms of IPSC
driven lol genic therapies there are two
main bottlenecks that are standing in
the way of this becoming more pronounced
in a setup first in a fight in my
opinion would be
cytogenetic instability how do we manage
a cohort of patients to better
understand as to why when the cure rate
increases
what are the new concerns about the late
effects of Gino toxic treatment and how
can we weigh against this toxicity and
even long-term sequelae
as in the pre
most condition
so there needs to be a flexibility to
integrate or bring in other alternatives
noble therapies to go side by side are
in conjugation with the therapy that the
clinicians are approaching the other
thing in my opinion which makes it
difficult or is definitely a gap in the
industry when it comes to hospitals and
this could be something maybe looking
into the future is postnatal banking if
we can store healthy say healthy stem
cells at birth so that it can be
reintroduced back into the patient with
the gene editing or cell therapeutic
techniques that would be hugely
beneficial and you know you know we can
have a much better clinical response
when we look forward to this sort of
allergenic treatments moving forward
thank you again Neil for your time today
and your important research do you have
any final comments for our audience yes
so you know one of the things that
really resonates with me in terms of
where we are today and where we are
moving forward as we go into the next
generation of cell therapy manufacturing
the the lab of the future will certainly
reflect the current trends in bioprocess
manufacturing and and eventually the
path from the bench to clinic will
require automation if we are to meet the
the GMP process criteria but most
importantly to to manage cost whether
the automation of this process will
proceed in a stepwise fashion or will it
be out Stanford fashion of like unit
operations as I talked about our our
will it be completely new noble ways of
approaching this time will tell but I
think I think we're living in that in a
time where you know it's definitely
exciting and and and it's it's it's a
wonderful time to understand how else we
can figure out more new and improved
cell therapies and us as tool providers
we will definitely be working with our
customers and clients to meet the
demands of this industry to deliver safe
effective and most importantly
affordable treatments
thank you
thank you again Neil we would also like
to thank laberd's and our sponsor
Beckman culture life sciences for
underwriting today's educational
webcasts before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through june of 2019 laboratory via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye